Speaker 1: I don't really care very much about
the White House Correspondents Association
dinner.
This is a dinner that Donald Trump would not
attend, but that typically presidents go to
and you schmooze with the people who are covering
your presidency.
Jokes are told they bring in comedians.
This year, the comedian was Trevor Noah.
It's not really an event I care about and
I thought about covering it live and then
decided I don't even really care about it.
I don't think I'm going to cover it.
But there are a few interesting moments from
it that I want to go over.
And these are from Joe Biden.
Now, of course, Joe Biden didn't write this
stuff, but it doesn't matter.
The points that that are made here are interesting
and they're pretty funny.
One aspect of this that was sort of controversial
was that to go to this event, you had to provide
proof that you were not only double vaccinated
against COVID, but also boosted.
And Fox News has a table or at least one table,
maybe multiple tables at this event.
And, of course, on air.
Fox News has run significant anti-vaccine
interference.
Hilariously, they were there.
And Joe Biden pointed out one of the great
things about this event is you can look at
the people sitting at the Fox News table,
know that regardless of what they're saying
on air, they are vaccinated and boosted.
Check this out.
Speaker 4: We're here to show the country
that we're getting through this pandemic.
Plus, everyone had to prove they're fully
vaccinated and boost it.
So if you're at home watching this and you're
wondering how to do that, just contact your
favorite fox news reporter.
They're all here vaccinated and boost it all
on.
Speaker 1: And there it cuts to Peter Doocy,
one of the main antagonists of White House
Press Secretary Jen Psaki.
I mean, listen, it it is on.
It is, on the one hand, a relatively kind
of cheap joke and obvious line.
And the people who most need to hear it probably
aren't watching this event.
But it is a great reminder that many of the
people making you question whether you should
go and get the COVID vaccine by using spurious
claims and non evidence based reporting.
They are vaccinated.
They're vaccinated.
And you could say, well, they're vaccinated
by force because they needed to in order to.
Well, not really.
I mean, Fox News had an option for not being
vaccinated.
You could choose to test daily if that's what
you wanted to do.
But they are making you hesitant to go and
get a vaccine.
They are vaccinated.
They are having a good time at the White House
Correspondents Dinner.
So that was a good moment.
Now, for all we know, they don't know they
bought fake vaccine cards.
Seems risky as a member of a prominent media
outlet to use a fake vaccination certificate
or card to get into a White House correspondents
dinner.
So probably not.
Laura Ingram, by the way, reportedly was there.
She's been a major anti-vaxx voice.
This confirms, if indeed she was there that
she's double vaccinated as well as boosted
Joe Biden with another funny line talking
about the plague and Trump.
I won't spoil it for you.
I'll just play it for you.
Speaker 4: The first time the president attended
this dinner in six years.
It's understandable.
We had a horrible plague, followed by two
years of COVID.
Speaker 1: I
know it's kind of cheesy, but I like it.
Speaker 4: Just imagine if my predecessor
came to this dinner this year.
Now, that would really have been a real coup
if that occurred.
Speaker 1: I don't know, guys.
I you know, this is not a policy thing, but
I liked what Biden did.
I thought it was the exact right sort of tone.
He also and I mean, he is taking on some very
serious issues.
The next topic he broached was these text
messages where we learned that Mark Meadows,
Trump's former chief of staff, as the insurrectionist
coup attempt, was going on.
He was texting with a variety of Fox News
hosts, including Sean HANNITY.
Everybody was kind of giving orders and strategizing
back and forth.
Really?
No, no fresh air between the administration
and Fox to speak of.
And Biden commented on that as well.
Take a look.
Speaker 4: Fox News, I'm I'm really sorry
your preferred candidate lost the last election
to make it up to you.
I'm happy to give my chief of staff to you
all so he can tell Sean HANNITY what to say
every day.
Speaker 1: And then the camera cutting to
Fox reporter John Roberts, who genuinely didn't
seem to like that.
Fox News really ridiculed during this, but
deservedly so.
I mean, Mark Meadows was texting Sean HANNITY
and telling him what to say.
And it's embarrassing and it's a joke and
it's pathetic.
So really nicely done.
I didn't really care for the sort of actual
comedians who did.
I just got super into it, although Trevor
Noah did have some funny lines, but Biden
got a bunch of good stuff there.
And these are important issues.
And to be perfectly frank, there might be
people who aren't even aware about some of
these things because they don't really watch
news, but they hear about this as an entertainment
event.
Maybe they watched it.
Maybe they go.
Text messages.
HANNITY Mark Meadows, what's up with that?
Let me look that up and go.
Wow.
Trump's chief of staff was telling Sean HANNITY
what to say.
That's not exactly fair and balanced news.
It's not even really news or reporting anyway.
It's just propaganda.
So nice job by Joe Biden.
Doesn't mean he's doing any better or worse
of a job as president.
He just did a nice job at the White House
Correspondents Dinner, which I generally,
generally speaking, don't care about.
But I did enjoy watching it this time